one year ago in Canada President Trump
suggested ray inviting Russia to g7
stating openly that Crimea's annexation
by Russia was partially justified and
that we should accept this fact under no
condition can we agree with this logic
when it comes to the speculations around
inviting Russia to the table I would
like to say this first the reasons why
Russia was disinvited in 2014 are still
valid what-ifs more there are new
reasons such as the Russian provocation
on the others see also tomorrow on the
margins of the summit I will have a
meeting with Prime Minister Boris
Johnson he will be third British
conservative Prime Minister with whom I
will discuss brexit the u.s. always open
to cooperation when David Cameron wanted
to avoid brexit when tourism a wanted to
avoid a No Deal brexit and she will also
be ready now to hold serious talks with
Prime Minister Johnson the one thing I
will not cooperate on if No Deal and I
still hope that Prime Minister Johnson
will not like to go down in history as
mr. No Deal we are willing to listen to
ideas that are operational realistic and
acceptable to all member states
including Ireland if and when the UK
government is ready to put them on the
table